maintenant vous allez comprendre
pourquoi je faisais allusion tout à
l'heure à geneviève de fontenay
il doit me regardez là haut dans la loge
car nous accueillons miss france
babafemi d'âge la télé mais j'ai dit
vous êtes jolie vraiment vous avez vu à
la télé mais là je vois comme ça quoi
oui 80 90 mais les jeunes bien réel et
là le point ne vient pas je ne viens
j'aime bien
mettez vous dis-je pas les noms suis
bien l'élever à battre ici de ce qu'on
peut apporter mes lignes vous avez un
siège pour borloo alors mis fin ce soir
on a vu des histoires incroyables à
rousseau qui était sur son canapé en
train de manger des chips qui galérait
un peu qu'ils n'ont pas 62 58
et donc là un ruisseau qui galèrent à un
peu plus aujourd'hui c'est la meilleures
ventes de singles en france 1 million
700 mille
voilà un bon voilà on a vu florence
arthaud tout à leur accident
sept tonneaux garges qu en deux ans
défiguré ne soit pas mais bon comme quoi
il ya toujours du haut avec bachelet et
qu'également voilà est alors encore une
histoire de femme extraordinaire c'est
vous voilà vous êtes un troisième
l'histoire de femmes extraordinaires de
la soirée alors on va le dire en deux
mots parce que c'est quand même une
histoire incroyable votre père est
français et au départ il quitte la
france à un moment un petit peu chagrin
d'amour en les uns peut le dire en
laissant deux enfants derrière lui un et
il va au rwanda voilà et au rwanda il a
le coup de foudre pour une dénommée
l'andra da une jeune femme de la
bourgeoisie tout si vous n'aimez pas
qu'on dise tutsis ou hutus vous préférez
qu'on en dise roanne dès lors comment
c'est à dire moi je trouve que faux culs
faire ces différenciations sinon on est
parti pour des guerres encore sert à
rien bien donc votre père arrive au
rwanda il tombe sur votre merle andrade
à 80 premiers résultats vous 84 deuxième
résultat votre petit frère voilà votre
père il a une petite entreprise
1 la crise voilà bien il a un bar
restaurant dancing qui s'appelle
l'auberge des mille collines
oui il n'empêche un peu chaud l'endroit
non mais dans les shows non c'était
cette annonce comme tous les autres
je sais pas demandez lui collina qu'ils
délivrent je peux vous dire que vous
avez connues bah oui c'est un peu un
lieu de rencontre quoi j'ai été connu
mon père j'ai connu des endroits surtout
non mais c'est un peu chaud l'endroit
quand même je sais pas ça je sais d'où
bon donc il avala s'il avait ce bar
restaurant dancing peut-être lieu de
rencontre on sait pas et là il commence
à voir la répression des hutus contre
les soutes si vous partez dans le pays
voisin burundi à bujumbura
et là ça recommence de nouveau des
troubles at on est reparti pour la
france
voilà les derniers jours c'était dur non
parce qu'il paraît qu'à un moment il y
avait vous étiez tellement flipper à
l'école que dès qu'ils avaient appris
une voiture qui a éclaté tout le monde
était à plat ventre dans l'école puis le
premier à partir c'était bien le direct
enfin le proviseur le proviseur de de
l'école française oui j'étais à l'école
française ouais on collège
et oui les premiers à partir alors vous
allez partir en france mais vous comme
n'ai pas beaucoup d'argent votre père
vend sa voiture n'est pas beaucoup
d'argent est obligé de prendre aeroflot
la compagnie soviétique par us mettez
trois jours pour faire le voyage pour
dépasser par ou sans qualification par
mois du coup pas le caire enfin tous
quitté le caire moscou tout ça s'est
fait manger du caviar avez quel âge à ce
moment-là vous aux environs de 12 13 ans
c'est la galère quoi ah oui ben on perd
tout on perd ses amis à votre père il
vient en france avec lui ni parce que
son père à lui il y avait une maison là
et le rmi
le rmi mamère dû tout recommencer mon
père aussi fins et on recommence tout à
zéro
ça lui devenu fraiseur tourneur un peu
moins drôle que s'il faisait est vrai
est passé de directeur de l'imprimerie à
ouvriers saadi c'est quand même un
métier quoi
tous les métiers sont nobles un pas pour
ça que mais bon c'est vrai que c'est un
peu indécent quand même pour lui à son
âge surtout mais votre mère ses diplômes
était pas malade donc les objets de le
recommencer les nains commencé oui on
n'a jamais compris pourquoi ils
n'étaient pas valables
ouais alors qu'elles aient toutes les
compétences pour le faire mais bon c'est
encore une qui vous a le plus surpris
c'est dire que vous êtes arrivé en
france c'est quoi je sais pas la
froideur des gens pensent que je suis
arrivé directement à paris bon paris
c'est vrai que les gens sont stupides je
sais pas c'est bizarre en afrique on est
plutôt posé on aime beaucoup sourire aux
gens alors on nous dit qu'on voulait
qu'on souriez dans le dans le métro dans
la rue on nous prenait pour des dingues
ouais vous avez beaucoup souffert du
racisme s'était simplement des
réflexions à ce que je disais vous avez
des réflexions du genre pourquoi tu es
noir tu t'es pas lavez-vous ressasser
les gosses passé entre nous un bon
danser les jeunes louis les gosses entre
mais j'ai été vraiment victimes de ces
gars c'est arrivé de trois femmes faire
mal mais non moi je sais faire face je
leur sourit au nez souriez comme ça c
est alors un jour dans la cage
d'escalier du hlm vous habitiez vous
croisez miss saône et loire oui eh ouais
et puis elle nous a pencher là-dessus
quoi m
mr à 2000 reste dans la famille quoi
n'est pas un rêve parce que ma mère
voulait quand même que je termine mon
bac
enfin quelques j'ai mon bac avant de
partir à participer à ces élections là
et bon ben on lui on lui a dit qu'on
pouvait faire les deux en même temps
puis on s'est dit quand même si j'ai une
fois dans sa vie quoi
le bac on peut leur passer chez vous à
brancher dans le show le comité
bourgogne j'ai été choisi pour le dire
quand même c'est une preuve incroyable
la bourgogne vous choisi vous pour la
représenter au niveau national c'est non
c'est celui marc simon oui c'est
formidable mais je l'avais remarqué
d'ailleurs ce soir d'élection linda
c'est quand on fait les gars là tout ça
les candidates on les aperçoit jets de
peinture mais là j'avais remarqué mais
qu'elle a régionaux ouais donc dur à ça
vous intéresse mais miss france à part
une barbie à l'âge où tu vois pas trop
non c'est un bon début il faut sortir
par le haut ça devait finir en
catastrophe mais faites attention bon
bah y'a pas de raison de s'inquiéter du
midi
si c'est vous qui le disent